In this segment, we want
to reinforce the message
that how you choose to sample
can give different results,
and the choice of
sampling is important.
Suppose you're interested in
measuring the average family
size in some population.
Suppose that there are
families that are small
and have just one
person in them,
and there's also a family
that has many people in it.
What does it mean to measure
the average family size?
One possibility is to pick at
random a family, each family
being chosen with
equal probability,
and talk about the expected
value that you get,
or the average value
if you sample that way.
In this particular example
with probability 1/4,
you get a 1, with
probability 1/4, you get a 1
with probability
1/4, you get a 1.
So the answer would be with
probability 3/4 you get a 1,
and with probability
1/4, you get a 6.
But suppose that instead,
you pick a person at random
and you ask for that person,
how big is your family?
What's the expected value of
the answer you're going to get?
Here we have nine people.
Out of those nine
people, 3 of them
will give you an answer
my family has size one,
and six of those people
will give you an answer,
my family has a size of six.
And this number is
going to be larger
than the previous number.
You're going to get
different answers.
So it is possible to
have a situation where
you can make a statement
such as the following.
The average family
size is three,
but the average person lives
in a family of size four.
There is no contradiction
between these two statements
because we're measuring
different things.
Another example of
the same flavor.
You're interested in the
average bus occupancy.
You're interested in whether
buses are crowded or not
in your city.
One way of carrying
out this calculation
is to pick buses
at random, each bus
is equally likely to
be picked, and see
how many people are
riding this bus.
Another possibility is to
take a typical passenger,
a random passenger, and ask
them, how crowded was your bus?
Take an extreme case.
Suppose that half of the
buses have 0 people in them,
and half of the buses
have 50 people in them.
If you look at random buses,
then the average occupancy
would be 25.
But if you ask passengers,
all of the passengers
would report 50, and it would
be, again, a different answer.
A similar situation is if you're
talking about average class
sizes.
One method is to look
at all the classes,
see how many students
there are in each class,
and take the average.
Another method would be
to ask a typical student,
how large is your class?
Because more students are
in large classes, when
you pick a student
at random, you
are likely to get a
higher answer, as opposed
to when you look
at a random class.
The moral from
all these examples
is that it is very
important to be
careful about what
you choose to sample.
When you pick at
random, what exactly
are you picking at random?
And you need to be aware
that different sampling
methods measure
different things,
and will generally give
you different results.